[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend das seit kriegsausbruch
gerade auch wirtschaftsminister und
finanzminister hierzulande dauereinsatz
sind zeigt wie sehr dieser krieg eben
auch ein wirtschaftskrieg ist nicht nur
wegen gas und öl auch weizen ist längst
zur waffe geworden als bundeskanzler
scholz heute erstmals wieder mit lade
mir putin telefonierte wies er diesen
auf die verantwortung russlands für die
globale lebensmittellager hin und darf
allerdings vermuten dass putin sehr
genau weiß was die ernteausfälle in der
ukraine und sein vorübergehenden
exportstopp für russischen weizen
bedeuten und dass das seinem kalkül
entspricht wie der westen darauf
reagieren sollte war eines der großen
themen heute beim treffen der g7
außenminister unter deutschem vorsitz
markus feldhoff berichtet
es ist ein bisschen glück dass die
deutsche außenministerin gleich in ihrem
ersten amtsjahr auch g7 präsidentin ist
aber annalena baerbock hat sich den
respekt erworben unter den kolleginnen
und kollegen der ukrainische der
moldawische außenminister der japanische
der italienische kollege oder die
britische außenministerin sie alle fügen
sich der agenda ihrer deutschen kollegin
baerbock macht gleich zu beginn der
ersten offiziellen arbeitssitzung der g7
klar dass sie längst weiter denkt der
krieg in der ukraine muss nicht nur eine
militärische antwort bekommen
der hybride krieg russlands ist nicht
nur ein krieg von panzern und raketen
von fake nutzen propaganda sondern auch
ein lebensmittel krieg dessen folgen wir
bereits in der ganzen welt sehen könnt
die ukraine ist eine große agra nation
25 millionen tonnen getreide liegen
derzeit allein in den speichern der
hafenstadt odessa und könnten dort
verrotten durch gekappte lieferwege
droht insbesondere afrika und dem nahen
osten eine hungersnot
sonnenblumenöl
maiskorn alles wird derzeit in der
ukraine festgehalten nicht wegen der
sanktionen nicht weil wir es nicht
exportieren wollen sondern einzig und
allein aufgrund der russischen
aggression und der blockade unserer
für den ukrainischen außenminister sind
die letzten zwei tage in deutschland
hoch effizient und wohl auch erfolgreich
bei den treffen mit der kanadierin julie
der britischen außenministerin trotz dem
hohen repräsentanten der eu borel oder
dem franzosen le trio gibt es nicht nur
warme worte sondern handfeste zu sagen
wir werden noch einmal 500 millionen
euro militärhilfe für die ukraine
aufbringen
insgesamt sind das dann zwei milliarden
euro
es ist sehr wichtig dass wir den druck
auf vladimir putin aufrechterhalten
durch mehr waffenlieferungen und
verschärfung der sanktionen und
zu noch einen vorschlag köhlers gibt es
viel zustimmung das russische
auslandsvermögen solle eingezogen und
zum wiederaufbau der ukraine genutzt
werden schließlich handelt es sich um
hunderte milliarden dollar
russland muss zahlen politisch
wirtschaftlich aber auch finanziell und
ich bin erfreut eine positive haltung
der g7 auf meinen vorschlag wahrgenommen
zu haben
der zusammenhalt des westens war lange
eine der schwierigsten aufgaben jeder g7
präsidentschaft derzeit gelingt es der
krieg schweißt sie zusammen
unterstützung für die ukraine
versprechen auch die parallel tagenden
landwirtschaftsministerin und minister
der g7-staaten millionen tonnen weizen
stecken fest doch wie soll man der
ukraine helfen sie zu exportieren werden
handelswege bombardiert werden und häfen
blockiert sind hinzu kommt dass die
russische armee offenbar in großem stil
weizen cloud und außer landes bringt
auch landwirtschaftsmaschinen wurden
gestohlen und traktoren zerstört unklar
ob der bauer hier auf eine landmine
gefahren ist oder beschossen wurde aber
so werden eben auch äcker zu
schlachtfeldern
die kriegsbedingten exporteinbrüche
trifft am schlimmsten afrikanische
länder die bisher große mengen weizen
aus der ukraine bezogen können die
europäer kann deutschland das
kompensieren allersberg berichtet
im juli wird dieser weizen reif für die
ernte sein wertvolles korn das durch den
ukraine krieg auf dem weltmarkt immer
teurer und knapper wird um dem
entgegenzuwirken einfach mehr weizen
anbauen hier in der nähe von stuttgart
das geht nicht ohne weiteres meint
landwirt rüdiger beck wir brauchen
prioritäten wie was machen sollen weil
wir zum einen klimaschutz zum einen
artenschutz zur ernährungssicherung wie
von sollen und auch tun aber natürlich
ein uns andere gleichzeitig zu tun das
portal nur schwer möglich sein denn
eigentlich schreibt die eu vor dass
künftig nicht mehrere male
hintereinander weizen auf der gleichen
fläche angebaut werden darf um den boden
zu schützen
bundesagrarminister cem özdemir will
sich jetzt dafür einsetzen diese
regelung zu verschieben nicht nur für
deutschland dafür wirkt er bei den
anderen agrarministern der sieben
größten industrienationen
also es geht um wertvolles getreide wo
landet des landes in den trögen landet
es in den im tank oder landet auf den
teller und die priorität eins muss ja
wohl sein im teller natürlich zuerst und
alles andere kommt danach heißt getreide
weniger in benzin mischen und weniger an
tiere verfüttert
aber das dürfte ein langfristiger
prozess werden
im augenblick sind wir eine situation wo
man eigentlich alle verfügbaren register
ziehen muss und sicherlich sind alle
schritte ein schritt in die richtige
richtung aber man sollte sich keine
illusionen machen dass einzelne
maßnahmen aufgrund der langfristigkeit
in der anbauplanung eben jetzt eine
völlige änderung der marktlage
herbeiführen könnten und das spiegeln ja
letztlich auch die preise einfach mehr
weizen anbauen reicht also bei weitem
nicht aus um der angespannten weltweiten
ernährungssituation angemessen
entgegenzuwirken und die reicheren
länder müssten langfristig ihren
fleischkonsum drastisch senken damit in
den ärmeren ländern mehr getreide auf
den teller kommt
darüber war mit dem
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister noch
sprechen abend erste mir
haben glaube ich so einen kleinen hänger
in unserer leitung dauert immer so im
moment bis sie mich hören aber davon
lassen wir uns nicht irritieren erste
mir ich würde mit dem letzten punkt der
im beitrag genannt wurde gleich anfangen
den fleischkonsum senken leider wird man
bei einem grünen landesverband
wirtschaftsminister offene türen
einlaufen aber das hilft
realistischerweise nicht jetzt im moment
die einbrechenden exporte aus der
ukraine zu kompensieren
es ist richtig aber es gibt kurzfristige
maßnahmen mittelfristige und
langfristige maßnahmen das gehört glaube
ich in den bereich mittelfristig was uns
da hilft fläche zu gewinnen in ihrem
beitrag konnte weil das ja hören frau
slomka wenn wir weniger tiere haben die
tiere mehr platz haben leisten ihren
beitrag zum klimaschutz leisten beitrag
zum tierschutz aber ganz wichtig die
bäuerinnen und bauern müssen auch geld
dafür bekommen denn sie haben dann
weniger einnahmen da arbeiten wir gerade
ich hoffe dass sich da bald was dazu
präsentieren kann wir gewinnen dann
fläche die wir direkt nutzen können für
menschliche ernährung für mehr getreide
ähnliches gilt für das thema beimischung
bei kraftstoffen auch da könnten wir
kurzfristig fläche gewinnen meine
kollegin umweltministerin ist der
initiative
bundeswirtschaftsminister ich
unterstützendes auch das hilft und jetzt
kurzfristig müssen wir unsere bäuerinnen
und bauern helfen wir haben 180
millionen aufgelegt von der
bundesregierung die mittel aus brüssel
noch mal kräftig erhöht aber also machen
müssen wir jetzt aber das alles ist
jetzt eigentlich unsere bauern die jetzt
indirekt bleiben sondern das geht ja vor
allen dingen um starten dann in afrika
oder auch in die türkei die sehr sehr
viel weizen aus der ukraine beziehen
also da müsste man doch eigentlich
gucken wie kriegt man dort jetzt mehr
hin und macht diese ausfälle aus der
ukraine weg
deshalb habe ich mich dafür eingesetzt
und der eu kommissar ist ja auch hier in
stuttgart wollte kowski und haben das
auch noch mal gesagt und die signale
sind positiv aus brüssel das weizen auf
weizen angebaut werden kann deshalb
erhöht die weizenerträge noch mal ganz
ganz kräftig ich habe mich gegen den
vorschlag entschieden was manche unions
kollegen wollten dass man wertvolle
ökologische flächen vielfalt flächen
dass man der pestizide dünner die gerade
kostbar und knapp sind dass man die dort
verschwendet mein vorschlag glaube ich
ist der bessere und ich krieg da gerade
sehr viel zustimmung dann geht es um
diese frucht folge wo die eu eigentlich
dafür sorgen wollte das jetzt nicht
zweimal hintereinander der gleiche
weizen auf dem boden getragen wird dann
sagt aber jetzt sogar die
welthungerhilfe bevor sich das ist also
ökologisch so unsinnig und damit werden
die böden so geschädigt also das ist
auch nicht der richtige weg scheint so
als dings ihn ein bisschen wie ihre
ministerkollegen habeck dass man das
eine mit dem anderen nämlich das
ökologisch und dass jetzt dringend
notwendige schlecht verbinden kann im
moment in dieser notlage
schauen sie wir sind in dieser situation
weil wir leider in der vergangenheit zu
wenig getragen haben für klimaschutz wir
haben zu wenig getan für den schutz der
biodiversität jeden tag verschwinden
arten die wechseln die kommen nicht
wieder und die haben dann sind die gibt
es ja nicht umsonst und die haben eine
wichtige funktion in natürlichen
kreisläufen jetzt haben wir den
schrecklichen angriffskrieg russlands
auf die ukraine die den bestehenden
hunger in der welt mit 800 millionen
menschen noch mal verschärft da kommen
neue dazu also müssen wir schauen wie
steigt man aus fossilen energieträgern
wie reduzieren die abhängigkeit von
mineralischem dünger das alles schaffen
aber nicht über nacht das braucht zeit
wir müssen schwierige entscheidungen
treffen ich mache das auch in der
landwirtschaftspolitik sie haben recht
mit ihrer kritik dafür zahlt man auch
einen preis wenn man weiter auf weizen
anbaut aber was ist denn die alternative
nichts tun kann ich die alternative
seien das wichtigste ist der krieg muss
enden in der ukraine
deshalb ist auch die solidarität mit der
ukraine so wichtig ganz interessant ist
ja dass es geht ja um exportzahlen vor
allem wenn gesagt wird 25 bis 30 prozent
des weizens kommen aus der ukraine und
aus russland da geht es nicht um die
gesamte weizenproduktion in der welt
sondern geht es um den den export dann
bricht man das anders ist das bei der
ukraine ungefähr einen anteil von zehn
prozent da hat er zb ein riese wie
indien gesagt wir würden gerne sehr viel
mehr exportieren wäre nicht dass eine
lösung zu sagen man versucht es erst mal
lieferketten zu verlegen anstatt jetzt
hier mit fruchtfolgen zu operieren oder
brachflächen flächen in deutschland zu
bepflanzen
das eine schließt das andere ja nicht
aus wir müssen unseren beitrag leisten
aber sie haben natürlich recht es gibt
große länder auf der welt da hätten wir
gerne dass sie keine
exportbeschränkungen machen sondern
aktiv sich einsetzen wir sind auch im
gespräch mit china das ist hier auch ein
thema und wir appellieren natürlich als
die sieben staaten dass die märkte offen
bleiben wenn jetzt jeder nur an sich
denkt man verschärft man die hungerkrise
dann schießen die preise noch mehr durch
die decke aber ich will noch mal sagen
bei der ukraine geht es jetzt auch zum
beispiel darum kriegen wir wenigstens
einen teil dessen was russland blockiert
in den häfen über die straße über die
schiene über die donau über alternative
wege raus der ukrainische minister der
auch hier anwesend ist teilweise hat uns
gesagt
25 tonnen sind da die sind abgeerntet
die sind in den silos jetzt kommt
möglicherweise die neue ernte dazu man
musste wirklich großen respekt haben vor
die bäuerinnen und bauern dort die
kämpfen tagsüber gegen den russischen
aggressor nacht sehen sie da kann man
wirklich nur den hut ziehen vor dem mut
der ukrainischen bäuerinnen und bauern
ein kind für das gespräch
bei der frage wie man etwa den hafen von
odessa sichern kann überhaupt exporte
noch zu ermöglichen sind wir bei der
militärischen seite dieses konflikts
deutschland ist mittlerweile ja auch
bereit der ukraine schwere waffen zu
liefern aber inwieweit wird das dann
auch umgesetzt der rüstungskonzern
rheinmetall erklärte heute erneut er
könnte innerhalb von drei wochen die
ersten marder schützenpanzer liefern
insgesamt hätten sie 100 stück im
angebot die die ukraine sehr gerne hätte
doch die bundesregierung habe dafür nach
wie vor keine erlaubnis erteilt auf der
anderen seite genehmigt die
bundesregierung die lieferung von
geparden panzern für diese aber leider
keine munition gibt
es sind solche themen zu denen der
verteidigungsausschuss des bundestags
heute den bundeskanzler befragte einige
fdp-abgeordnete scheinen die antworten
oder nicht antworten des kanzlers
ziemlich entnervt zu haben aus berlin
andrea macher
am morgen kommt der kanzlerin den
verteidigungsausschuss ein tag voller
unstimmigkeiten und widersprüche beginnt
eine stunde lang soll scholz seine
ukraine politik erklären wie gut er das
getan hat darüber gehen die
interpretationen in koalition und
opposition auseinander
sehr transparent in sehr großen linien
den kurs der bundesregierung in aller
entschlossenheit und entschiedenheit
geschildert auf die frage hin wann denn
jetzt eigentlich der gepard tatsächlich
für die ukraine verfügbar ist gab es
leider keine antwort es gab auch keine
antwort ob die ukraine
denn gebhard überhaupt angefordert oder
darum gebeten hat gab es keine antwort
und es gab auch keine antwort darauf
welche anderen waffensysteme die ukraine
dann möglicherweise tatsächlich
angefragt habe was sich dann abzeichnet
bezeichnen die einen als am p klar und
versuchen die anderen runter zu spielen
der verteidigungspolitische sprecher der
fdp markus ferber und drei andere fdp
abgeordnete sollen die sitzung vorzeitig
verlassen haben aus protest über das
nicht antworten des kanzlers fahrer
bestätigt dass in einem interview wir
hatten heute den bundeskanzler von 8 bis
9 im verteidigungsausschuss zu gast ich
finde er hat hier wirklich die chance zu
erklären wie sie die position der
bundesregierung zur unterstützung der
ukraine ist im wurden da auch sehr viele
fragen gestellt leider wurden sehr viele
fragen noch nicht beantwortet
deswegen haben wir als freie demokraten
um kurz nach 9 entschieden dass wir die
sitzung jetzt verlassen die spd spricht
von einem unangemessenen vorgang die fdp
spitze ist verärgert 5 marcus faber
zurück wenig später wird faber dem
kanzler plötzlich für den zitat
konstruktiven besuch danken und die
vorsitzende des verteidigungsausschusses
marie-agnes strack-zimmermann fahrers
fdp kollegin die den kanzler selbst
eingeladen hatte weil sie in drängen
wollte fragen klar zu beantworten
sie wird mühe haben den vorgang klein zu
halten ein kollege von mir hat etwas
früher die sitzung verlassen
weil die sitzung länger ging als 9 uhr
also erstmal an der stelle vielen dank
dass der kanzler sich die zeit genommen
hat nein wenn einer früher den raum
verlässt dann ist das eine abgeordnete
unbenommen das ist keiner klar wichtiger
ist was der kanzler gesagt hat da die
vorsitzende hat ohne absprache ein
bundeskanzler scholz eingeladen das
haben wir im grunde auch begrüßt damit
wir antworten bekommen vom bundeskanzler
scholz aber die fdp hat auch fragen
gestellt die nicht geantwortet worden
sind jetzt ist es der vorsitzenden quasi
auf die füße gefallen man kann auch
sagen die geister die sie rief die wird
sie jetzt nicht los wie gravierend der
vorgang in der fdp ist zeigt sich daran
dass kurzfristig der fraktionsvorstand
dazu getagt hat am ende des tages bietet
fahrer seinen rücktritt vom
sprecherposten an was vom kanzler besuch
im verteidigungsausschuss bleibt
unstimmigkeiten in der fdp die als
unstimmigkeiten in der ampel
interpretiert werden können eine
steilvorlage für die opposition
mit dem krieg gegen die ukraine geht es
jetzt in den nachrichten erst noch immer
weiter in einem ersten prozess beginnt
die ukrainische justiz damit mutmaßliche
kriegsverbrechen russische soldaten
aufzuarbeiten so eine vor anhörung heute
musste ein 21 jähriger russischer soldat
vor einem bezirksgericht in ihrer schale
er soll ende februar einen 62-jährigen
unbewaffneten zivilisten erschossen
haben die ukraine wirft der russischen
armee vor seit kriegsbeginn zahlreiche
kriegsverbrechen begangen zu haben dem
beschuldigten droht eine lebenslange
haftstrafe
ein russisches unternehmen der strom
nach finnland importiert hat kurzfristig
einen lieferstopp angekündigt wie das in
helsinki ansässige unternehmen rau und
nordic mitteilte kann von morgen an kein
strom mehr aus russland fließen
hintergrund ist demnach angeblich eine
ausgebliebene zahlung der lieferstopp
kommt zeitgleich mit den beratungen in
finnland über einen möglichen nato
beitritt ministerpräsidentin marin und
präsidentin ist hatten sich gestern
ausdrücklich dafür ausgesprochen
das nato mitglied türkei hat vorbehalte
gegen einen möglichen beitritt finnlands
und schwedens zu dem militärbündnis
angemeldet präsident erdogan sagte man
beobachte derzeit die entwicklungen
bezüglich schwedens und finnlands aber
habe keine positive meinung dazu das
skandinavische länder seien geradezu
gasthäuser für terrororganisationen wie
die verbotene kurdische arbeiterpartei
pkk
in den sicherheitsbehörden von bund und
ländern sind in den vergangenen drei
jahren
327 personen aufgefallen die
nachweislich bezüge zu rechtsextremismus
oder der sogenannten reichs bürger szene
haben das geht aus einem neuen
lagebericht hervor den innenministerin
feser vorgestellt hat die ganz
überwiegende mehrzahl der mitarbeiter
stehe aber fest auf dem boden des
grundgesetzes betonte feser
gegen den 16-jährigen jugendlichen aus
essen der wegen mutmaßlicher
anschlagspläne
vorläufig festgenommen worden war ist
haftbefehl erlassen worden er ist jetzt
in untersuchungshaft
ihm wird nach angaben von polizei und
staatsanwaltschaft vorgeworfen einen
rechtsextremistisch motivierten anschlag
in der von ihm besuchten schule
vorbereitet zu haben
bei einer messerattacke in einer
regionalbahn bei aachen hat ein mann
fünf menschen verletzt laut polizei hat
der täter wahllos auf mitreisende
eingestochen er konnte von passagieren
überwältigt und dann von der polizei
festgenommen werden der 31 jährige
stammt aus dem irak und galt bei den
behörden 2017 als islamistische prüf
fall für die tat heute gibt es nach
angaben der ermittler bisher keine
hinweise auf ein islamistisches motiv
wenn am sonntag die nordrhein westfalen
gewählt wird wird man sicher wieder
reihum den begriff der kleinen
bundestagswahl hören das mag manchmal
etwas übertrieben seien auch die
nordrhein westfalen schauen auf
regionale themen und persönlichkeiten
aber wenn das bevölkerungsreichste
bundesland zur wahlurne ruft dann ist
das schon eine große hausnummer
enttäuschende ergebnisse werden am
sonntag auch nicht als rein regionale
angelegenheit abgetan werden können und
die wahl könnte auch bundespolitische
langzeitfolgen haben die cdu etwa muss
ich ja irgendwann gedanken über künftige
kanzlerkandidaten worte verpackt
berichtet
wahlkampfabschluss im münsterland der
heimat von cdu-spitzenkandidat hendrik
wüst auf dem gelände einer firma für
lastwagen anhänger und mit kiels
ministerpräsident daniel günther als
glücksbringer der vor einer woche
geschafft hat was wüst noch schaffen
will du hast die regierungsauftrag in
schleswig holstein und genau darum geht
es jetzt in diesen nächsten stunden und
tagen auch hier bei uns in nordrhein
westfalen dass wir das stärkste ergebnis
kriegen von allen parteien die anträgen
dass wir vorne sind und dass wir damit
einen regierungsauftrag haben schafft
wüst es ministerpräsident zu bleiben
dürfte er mit 46 jahren auch der
kommende mann der cdu sein schaffte es
nicht hätte die cdu nach dem kanzleramt
auch das größte bundesland verloren und
ein dickes problem das sieht bei der spd
nicht anders aus die gesamte
parteispitze ist nach köln gereist
parteichef ministerpräsident innen und
der kanzler selbst sie alle wollen ihren
nrw mann thomas kutschaty unterstützen
dass wir heute hier so stehen hören mit
geraden kreuzungen geraden rücken und
sagen können wir sind eine
selbstbewusste
sozialdemokratie die wahlen gewinnen wir
das haben wir ganz vielen zu verdanken
euch in den anderen ländern die uns
unterstützt haben aber insbesondere auch
der bundes partei nach dem wahlsieg im
bund wollte die spd ein
sozialdemokratisches jahrzehnt einleiten
das wäre mit einer niederlage in
düsseldorf gleich nach kiel schnell
beendet
auch die grünen setzen in düsseldorf auf
bundesprominenz
wirtschaftsminister habeck wird von nrw
spitzenkandidatin mona neubauer als
tatkräftig gepriesen sowas strebe sie
auch an
nordrhein westfalen braucht politik mit
haltung politik die erklärt politik die
ehrlich kommuniziert die lernfähig ist
nach so vielen krisen morgen kommt noch
die außenministerin die beliebtheit
ihrer stars berbalk und harbeck hilft
den grünen am rhein die fdp hat
finanzminister lindner an den
niederrhein geladen der stammt immerhin
aus nrw
spitzenkandidaten auch im stamm braucht
jede unterstützung bei umfragewerten von
6% es muss mobilisiert werden und
stärken sie uns dass wir so stark werden
am sonntag dass keine regierung ohne uns
gebildet werden kann dann geht es weiter
mit dort westfalen nach vorne nicht
zurück mit der afg will keine andere
partei koalieren die abschlusskundgebung
in krefeld fand schon vor einer woche
statt je stärker wir werden desto mehr
druck werden wir auf diejenigen
entfalten können die mit ihrer politik
die letzten jahren einfach sagen
angerichtet haben werde ich es
ihresgleichen sucht weil david herren
wer regiert das größte bundesland dieses
wahlergebnis wird folgen haben weit über
düsseldorf hinaus
das bundeswirtschaftsministerium stellt
in seinem neuen monatsbericht zur
wirtschaftlichen lage eine reihe von
belastungen und unwägbarkeiten fest
neben dem krieg in der ukraine zählt
dazu auch die korona lage in china frank
bethmann wie wirken sich die locker und
sind china aus ja da braut sich was
zusammen das ganze ausmaß der
verwerfungen dürfte erst in einigen
wochen zu spüren sein wenn die waren die
derzeit nicht produziert in den regalen
fehlen werden nicht umsonst lenkt der
monatsbericht nun den fokus auf chinas
immer größer werdenden probleme und auf
die gefahren die das für uns birgt von
der weltweiten container frachtkapazität
stehen derzeit drei prozent allein im
hafen vor shanghai im stau heißt es dort
china ist 2016 der wichtigste
handelspartner deutschlands allein im
vergangenen jahr wurden waren im wert
von über 2 145 milliarden euro zwischen
beiden ländern gehandelt immer
einseitiger hat sich die deutsche
industrie auf china ausgerichtet ob für
volkswagen bmw oder mercedes für alle
avancierte das reich der mitte zum
wichtigsten einzelmarkt
möglicherweise noch rechtzeitig fängt
jetzt in vielen unternehmenszentralen
ein umdenken statt die neue strategie
heißt mehr distanz selbstverständlich
auch gespeist von den jüngsten
erfahrungen im russlandgeschäft so ganz
passen die sorgen heute freilich nicht
zum dax der kann nämlich zum
wochenschluss kräftig über zwei prozent
oder fast
290 punkte zulegen im
bundeswirtschaftsministerium aber bleibt
man trotzdem skeptisch denn je länger
die weltweiten krisen dauern desto
schwerer treffen die folgen wohl auch
deutschland frank bethmann vielen dank
der journalist und publizist deniz yücel
hat überraschend seinen rücktritt als
präsident des deutschen pen-zentrums
erklärt und seinen austritt aus der
schriftstellervereinigung zuvor war bei
der mitgliederversammlung in gotha ein
antrag auf seine abberufung mit knapper
mehrheit abgelehnt worden hintergrund
sind interne querelen in der
führungsriege
die deutsche eishockey
nationalmannschaft hat zum auftakt in
die wm in finnland eine niederlage
kassiert das team von bundestrainer
tonis oder holz unterlag in helsinki dem
titelverteidiger und rekordweltmeister
kanada mit 3 zu fünf zum tennis
alexander zverev hat es ins halbfinale
des atp-masters in rom geschafft er
gewann gegen den chilenischen
sandplatzspezialisten christian gehring
in zwei sätzen
es wäre vom boden ja aber das nur ein
sinnbild für seinen einsatz nicht für
seine leistung denn die ist deutlich
besser als in den runden zuvor der erste
satz noch hart umkämpft dabei mit dem
besseren ende für zverev schönen
rückhand longline
zu fünft das ergebnis danach der
widerstand ist die lehnen christian gar
ihn dahin zwei schnelle breaks im
zweiten satz deutlich die führung für
zverev und dann der matchball zum 6 2
letztlich ein souveräner zweisatzerfolg
der hoffen lässt für das halbfinale
[Applaus]
das war es von uns an diesem
freitagabend und damit ist auch klar wie
es hier weitergeht freitag heute show
und danach will man 120 dann gundula
gause mit unserem heutigen update ist
auch wieder da bis dahin wieder sehen
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum wetter heute
abend ja besser das wird auch jetzt am
wochenende wieder ein thema denn das
wochenende wird sonnig trocken und sehr
warm und das fast überall denn aus dem
westen nähert sich ein hoch dass wolken
und regen aus dem land trinkt und so
lassen heute nacht auch die letzten
schauer nun im süden und ganz im
nordosten nach in der mitte ist es klar
und der kräftige westliche winter hat ja
über tag ein paar wolken in den norden
gebracht die locker noch in der nacht
kaum auf und unter den wolken haben wir
morgen früh temperaturen im
zweistelligen bereich 10 11 grad bei
klarem himmel da wird aber recht frisch
morgen früh 4 bis 9 grad über tag
steigen die temperaturen dann aber
schnell an meistens erreichen sie 22 bis
26 grad ganz im norden da kommen wir
nicht ganz an die 20 grad-marke das
liegt zum einen an dem weiter frischen
westlichen wind zum anderen an den
wolken die sich hier mit der sonne
abwechseln nichtsdestotrotz scheint die
sonne aber auch hier sieben bis elf
stunden in der mitte und im süden des
landes strahlt sie sogar 15 stunden und
nur an den alpen da gibt es gegen abend
auch mal ein einzelnes gewitter am
sonntag da scheint dann auch im
nordosten des landes die sonne fast
ungestört wir erreichen eventuell 30
grad vor allem am rheingraben aber
dieses ruhige wetter nimmt dann am
montag ein fulminantes ende da kommt aus
südwesten gewitter mit unwetterpotenzial
und die beschäftigen uns dann auch am
dienstag noch weiter auf wiedersehen